we've got a skin care trend that i want
to get your beauty brain on okay
cosmetology reports the latest
ingredient in skin hydration is
something you didn't expect it's a snail
mucin which is a protein in snail mucus
it's defined as a thick fluid with a
slimy texture that is released when a
snail is agitated some dermatologists
say it's actually good for plumping and
hydration and some formulations contain
antioxidants and a bunch of other gunk
and i have it here and i'm gonna rub it
on my face what are you going to do look
this is snail slime i actually ordered
this it took forever because they sent
it snail mail
[Laughter]
stupid
but do i have that like do you just want
to slug me
how do i look with some snail mucus on
me um i appreciate that when a sl when a
snail gets agitated
that that agitation is worth something
because when i get agitated nothing good
comes out nothing no beauty product
comes out of you nothing i will say uh
because i have a company flower beauty
i've taken a lot of trips um to
uh korea and south korea where
the they're the best in innovation and
snails have been on trend there for
years really oh yeah everybody's
snailing over over there this is this is
very well known but i feel like this is
a new part of it or
they've discovered you know again maybe
when it's agitated it produces something
even more useful kyle what happens when
you get agitated
um i i kind of just shut down and stop
talking to people
was thinking i mean like
listen no no shade on people who use
snail music
i think my wife told me she uses it so i
don't want to i don't want to talk smack
but if if we're allowed to do this i'm
thinking maybe i should be able to allow
to just like throw boogers all over me
listen
trust me kyle if
women
thought that it would euthan them or
dewey them or plump them i guarantee you
we'd be boogering i'm not kidding
[Applause]
people will stop at nothing
for beauty they're like if i have to
wipe a snail across my face to look
younger guess what yeah i'm doing it it
works you guys i just want to say this
company you guys totally snailed it it
looks great ah kyle you're the next
story okay
next up uh travel and leisure reports
there's one food you should never order
on a flight it's pasta why why
experts say
don't eat the pasta at 36 000 feet uh
it's going to be much city all plain
food is reheated in the air so that
double cooked pasta is gonna have the
consistency of slop and secondly a carbo
load on the flight makes your blood
sugar spike and then fall so you might
end up a sleepy cranky baby when you
land
[Laughter]
i think they also said in the article
like best practice is to pack
your own meal
like i'm not saying i i had i had a zd
on my flight to new york like a week ago
a bake ziti or something on the flight
yeah wow fancy i always order the
chicken because i love and i have good
taste but i love dried chicken right
there's something i get so excited you
know who i am on the plane like i'm
always like the tray out the thing there
like this even if they're just serving
crackers i'm like hi hi i'm ready can i
have the cracker now
i take it so seriously and i one time
switched my loyalty like i was i always
flew this one airline and then i
switched to another one because the new
airline had fresca and that's why i fly
to airlines
to this day well next it's a pick from
um drew's little yellow book yes it has
my name in it
today i'm really excited because kyle is
contributing to the book so kyle what is
your
little yellow book pick well yeah so i i
work at i work at 30 rock which is not
too far from from where we're at right
one of the most famous buildings in the
world and uh
there is a whole all cart there at 44th
and 6th ave called royal grill i am
there at least
twice a week it's one of those food
carts we didn't get food on the street
on the street it's a whole all car haul
truck yeah and uh i'm there constantly
this is the only thing i pretty much
consistently eat every week um i will
say also i feel like i'm slightly
burying the lead i do
i have my royal grill halal
food is so funny
[Applause]
uh i'm one away from
either a tikki masala combo over rice
cotty roll or chicken biryani and uh i'm
gonna buy my next one and i'm gonna get
that three oh my god i love a man with a
punch card listen
pepper jack
food truck
there you got the red sauce the white
sauce the green sauce what sauce do you
do
i do all three they kind of at this
point they know my order so i just show
up and and they uh they throw it all on
can you tell me what this order is what
am i eating
you may you might have the the
combo which could be lamb and chicken
i also get the chicken tikka a lot or
the chicken over rice
get some falafel
uh the cotty rolls are great you see i'm
dipping drew i do this they call me i
like a lot of sauces they're matthias
sauce matthews
[Applause]
the mint sauce is incredible and then
i've heard
really popular
um reviews on the cream sauce which i'm
about to have which is like a
creamy garlic sauce
mm-hmm
mm-hmm it's incredible yes yeah i'm
gonna get myself a punch card
okay
go support them they're awesome
well if you want to continue the joy
factor catch obviously kyle on saturday
night live but saturday morning all-star
hits on netflix is out right now and i
have to tell you i think that it is so
wonderful it is a combo plate of
goodness and you've done something
really fantastic
[Music]
you